what's up everybody this is zaki from
geek culture and today we have a very
special unboxing of the highly
anticipated game of the year death
stranding that will be released
worldwide on the 8th of november there
will be two unboxings in this video the
limited edition ps4 pro bundle and the
collector's edition featuring the
one-to-one scale bb part figure
the dash training limited edition ps4
pro console bundle box presents the main
protagonist in the game sam porter
bridges played by norman readers in his
iconic outfit and embracing his bb pod
flip it to the back and we see a
stunning printout of sam scouring
through the lands of united cities of
america
out of the box we have a custom designed
one terabyte ps4 pro a copy of the dev
stranding game and a custom dual shock 4
wireless controller
the ps4 pro comes decked in white with
inky black handprints dripping down the
top and equally as impressive is the
devs trending logo printed in gold on
the middle of the black media bar
what's more intriguing is the
controller's design
its semi-transparent yellow palette
color scheme takes a nod to sam's iconic
companion
[Music]
next is the death stranding collector's
edition featuring sam bridges yet again
but now blown up covering the whole box
this box alone simply screams bragging
rights to show off to your friends on
the back you get a detailed list of
what's inside accompanied by sam again
looking over the horizon
before we get to the physical goodies
let's hop over to the digital items that
comes with the collector's edition
some sweet sweet downloadable content
that you can redeem on the playstation
network you get a copy of the devs
trending time fall which is the original
music of the game as well as behind the
scenes digital video
some exclusive in-game items all prized
in gold the gold luden's mass sunglasses
gold power skeleton gold armor plate and
a gold all-terrain skeleton
now for the physical goodies we get a
fully loaded bridges cargo case
a custom printed steelbook case a copy
of the game
a roll of custom printed death stranding
damage sensor tape perfect for keeping
depth trending spoilers at bay you'll
also get an android more ludens
minifigure and of course the one-to-one
scale bb part
this figure packs in details down to the
minutiae
including various nuts and bolts affixed
to the pods side and bottom
various catches and buttons that look
identical to the game the baby in the
pod is certainly one to one and it looks
so realistic you could almost swear it
could move at some point and to add
further immersion there are led lights
situated at the base of the bb pod as
well as inside which are powered by two
aaa batteries perfect when you're
navigating with bb in the dark
with that we hope you enjoyed this
unboxing of the dev stranding limited
edition ps4 pro console bundle and the
death trending collector's edition if
you would like to know more about these
goodies be sure to check out the link in
the description below
also if you haven't read our review of
the game do check it out
don't forget to slam that subscribe
button and tell us about what you would
like us to unbox next
see you on the next one until then stay
geeky